- Alright, before we say goodbye,
I have one more great story to
share on this Veteran's Day.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
This has always been a source
of healing for veterans,
including dance,
And in Florida a retired
veteran switched out
his combat boots for tap shoes.
(jazz music)
(cheering) That's Mack Max,
the veteran known Major Mac.
He's the founder of the Veterans
Art Center in Tampa Bay.
We have him on the line right now watching
on Tampa Bay's MOR-TV.
What's up Major Mac?
- Hey. Hey, hey.
What's up?
(cheering)
What's going on in New York?
- Oh man, well, how long did it take you
to learn how to tap?
- Oh, it took me about five weeks.
Lindsey White, my instructor,
was my drill sergeant for five weeks.
So, we did a tap dance instruction
and for our dance party
when Hurricane Ian hit
at Fred Astaire, we had
this tap dancing theme
and all of my board members
are like, Major Mac,
Major Mac, can you do a tap dance?
And I said, yeah, anything
to bring in people
and create memories and laughter.
- Yeah, and it feels good.
I used to tap when I was a kid, it's fun.
- [Major Mac] Yeah.
- So this, there's a serious reason
behind this though, right?
- Yeah, so I retired out of USF St. Pete
and US Army Cadet Command
and running in downtown St. Petersburg.
I had this epiphany to start a
center for military veterans,
first responders and families
and actually this is our 10th
year anniversary as well.
And so we do mental health
healing and suicide prevention
and we're up to four
prevented suicides right now.
Currently we reached out
around 2,000, 2,500 veterans
with our various programs that
we have done and are doing.
- Wow, well thank you so much Major Mac.
(cheering)
I'm liking your posts right now, right?
- [Major Mac] Yes.
(dinging)
- And that's actually not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
believe in your efforts
to support veterans.
So they're gonna be writing
the Veterans Art Center of
Tampa Bay a check for $1,000.
What's the sound?
(cheering)
Thank you so much Major Mac
and thank you to all our guests this hour:
Al Roker, Deborah Roberts,
Matt Rife, Major Sam Winkler,
Staff Sargent Karen Vargas,
Greg Morgan and Jelly Roll.
And a big thank you to all
the men and women serving
and sacrificing for our country.
We salute you, we thank
you, we appreciate you.
Have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.